pour jean sillonnent les rues de bombay
à vélo chaque matin pour récupérer des
boîtes à lunch la pollution et la
congestion c'est son quotidien depuis 14
ans je suis habitué dit il c'est un jeu
d'enfant
le plus vieux système de livraison de
nourriture du monde à 125 ans les dab
awala livre des plats faits maison
pas de la nourriture de restaurants
cette dame a préparé du chou fleur et
des petits pois en sauce pour un oncle
parti travailler très tôt la nourriture
est meilleure pour la santé que celles
des restaurants déclare-t-elle
pour 800 roupies par mois soit environ
14 dollars un client reçoit chaque jour
sa boîte à lunch au bureau même si ce
lieu de travail peut être très loin de
la maison
le vaste réseau de trains de banlieue
normalement bondé avant la pandémie est
une partie essentielle de la vie du
grand bombay souci un maillon important
du système de dabakala les boîtes à
lunch sont durs et à leur gare de
destination est référée par d'autres
livreur
des clients utilisent les débats walla
pour s'assurer de respecter les
restrictions alimentaires imposés par
leur religion ou leur caste
cet homme est un adepte de la religion
jane
il est végétarien mais il ne peut
consommer aucun légumes cultivés sous le
sol ce ne sont pas tous les restaurants
qui servent de la nourriture appropriée
pour moi dit il
l'université considère ce système à
l'ancienne comme un modèle
d'organisation logistique
les livreurs font moins de trois erreurs
et demi par million de transactions
europe handling ils connaissent leurs
clients et suivent ce code à la lettre
pas besoin d'applications mobiles
stations de train de provenance et de
destination numéro de l'édifice où le
repas sera livré et codes personnels du
livreur est de voter oui ça m'arrive de
faire une erreur avoue bourde gîte mais
j'ai le temps de la corriger le jour
même
comme beaucoup d'entreprises à travers
le monde les débats wallace ont menacé
par la pandémie
or use a browser orji touche la moitié
de son salaire d'avant la pandémie il a
dû changer son mode de vie et il craint
maintenant pour sa santé mais il est un
des chanceux qui a encore un emploi des
250 livreur qui travaillait dans son
quartier
il n'en reste plus que 40 en raison de
la pandémie
le plus vieux système de livraison de
nourriture espère se relancer en
ajoutant des services
la livraison à domicile de produits de
la ferme pourrait être une planche de
salut
ici philippe leblanc radio-canada bombay